IN THE CHEST AND CAUSED THIS
SORT OF COMMOTION --
>> WE'RE JUMPING OVER TO CAPITOL
HILL.
KEVIN McCARTHY IS SPEAKING TO
REPORTERS.
>> I'VE BEEN LEADER FOR FOUR
YEARS.
I CAME INTO THIS POSITION, WE
HAD LESS THAN 200 MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOW SITTING IN THE
MAJORITY.
WE PUT FORTH TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC A COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
THERE IS TIMES WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO ARGUE WITH OUR OWN
MEMBERS IF THEY'RE LOOKING AT
ONLY POSITIONS FOR THEMSELVES
AND NOT FOR THE COUNTRY.
FOR LAST TWO MONTHS WE WORKED
TOGETHER AS A WHOLE CONFERENCE
TO DEVELOP RULES THAT EMPOWER
ALL MEMBERS.
BUT WE'RE NOT EMPOWERING CERTAIN
MEMBERS OVER OTHERS.
LAST NIGHT I WAS PRESENTED THE
ONLY WAY TO GET 218 VOTES IF I
PROVIDED CERTAIN POSITIONS OR
GAVELS AND HAVE CERTAIN BUDGETS
AND THEY EVEN CAME TO THE
POSITION WHERE ONE MATT GAETZ
SAID I DON'T CARE IF GO TO
PLURALITY AND WE ELECT HAKEEM
JEFFRIES AND IT HURTS THE FRONT
LINE MEMBERS NOT TO GET
RE-ELECTED.
THAT IS NOT ABOUT AMERICA.
I'LL PUT AMERICA FIRST NOT A FEW
INDIVIDUALS.
BUT THE BATTLE IS FOR THE
CONFERENCE AND THE COUNTRY AND
THAT IS FINE WITH ME.
>> WHAT DO YOU -- YOU HAVE A
MATH PROBLEM YOU CAN'T GET
THERE.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO ON THE TENTH
VOTE, THE 30th VOTE, IF IT
DOESN'T MOVE.
>> I HAVE THE RECORD FOR THE
LONGEST SPEECH EVER ON THE
FLOOR.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM GETTING A
RECORD FOR MOST VOTES.
THANK YOU ALL.
>> BUT THAT DOESN'T --
>> I DON'T SEE HOW A FEW PEOPLE,
MAYBE IT IS FIVE OR 20, SIT
BECAUSE THEY WANT A GAVEL THAT
THEY CAN'T EARN BY THE
CONFERENCE OF THEM SFZ.
THAT IS INTERESTING TO ME.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE
CONSTITUENTS VOTED THEM FOR.
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU HAVE KEVIN McCARTHY COMING
OUT REALLY KIND OF UNANNOUNCED
FROM WHAT HAS BEEN NOW AT THIS
POINT A MORE THAN AN HOUR, MORE
THAN AN HOUR BEHIND CLOSED DOOR
WITH THE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE
IN THE BASEMENT OF THE CAPITOL.
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO WORK OUT
WHAT CAN BE DESCRIBED AS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT AS HILL DRAMA.
THIS IS BEEN KIND OF A HISTORIC
AMOUNT OF INTERPARTY BATTLE OVER
WHAT KEVIN McCARTHY HAS BEEN
VYING FOR, FOR SO LONG, WHICH IS
TO GET THE SPEAKER'S GAVEL.
AS THEY GAVEL IN THE NEW
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY.
LET ME BRING IN DAVID CHALIAN
AND CNN CHIEF CORRESPONDENT MANU
RAJU ON THIS.
THEY JUST CAME OUT.
AND McCARTHY MAKING IT CLEAR
HE'S READY TO HAVE A FLIGHT ON
THE FLOOR.
THINGS DIDN'T SIMMER DOWN BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS, JUST NOW?
>> YEAH, LOOK, KATE, I'VE
COVERED A NUMBER OF THE CLOSED
DOOR MEETINGS.
THIS IS ABOUT AS CONTENTIOUS AS
IT GETS.
PEOPLE WERE CURSING AT OECH
OTHER AND GOING BACK AND FORTH.
THE LEADER MAKING CLEAR THAT HE
IS NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
KEVIN McCARTHY SAID THAT DESPITE
ALL OF THE PUSH TO GET HIM OUT
THERE BY A HANDFUL OF MEMBERS.
HE'S MADE CONCESSION AFTER
CONCESSION AFTER CONCESSION.
SAYING HE'S NOT READY TO GO
THERE.
NOT READY TO GO EVEN FURTHER.
OTHERS PUSHING BACK.
HE GOT INTO A BACK AND FORTH AND
EXTENDED EXCHANGE WITH CHIP ROY
OF TEXAS.
HE GOT INTO ANOTHER ONE WITH
SCOTT PERRY OF PENNSYLVANIA.
ANOTHER PERSON WHO HAS INDICATED
THAT HE'S LIKELY TO VOTE AGAINST
HIM.
SAYING THAT WE ARE -- WE HAVE TO
MOVE FORWARD HERE AND A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE COMING TO HIS DEFENSE
SAYING THAT KEVIN McCARTHY WAS
NOMINATED BY HI CONFERENCE AND
DESERVES TO BE ELECTED SPEAKER
AND HIMSELF SAYING THAT HE HAS
EARNED THIS JOB.
BUT ONE THING THAT DID NOT
CHANGE, KATE, IS THE MATH.
HE STILL HAS A MATH PROBLEM.
BECAUSE OF THE NARROWNESS OF THE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY.
222 SEATS THEY WILL NOT OCCUPY.
THAT MEANS HE COULD ONLY LOSE
FOUR REPUBLICAN VOTES ON THE
FLOOR.
THERE ARE MORE THAN FOUR
REPUBLICAN VOTES WHO PLAN TO
VOTE AGAINST HIM.
SEVERAL MEMBERS COMING OUT JUST
TOLD ME THEY ARE STILL HARD NO.
PEOPLE LIKE BOB GOOD, ANDY
BIGGS, CHIP ROY WHO I MENTIONED
SIGNALING HE'S A NO AND SCOTT
PERRY AS WELL.
THE LIST COULD BE UP TO TEN, 14,
MAYBE EVEN 20 MEMBERS VOTING
AGAINST McCARTHY ON THE FIRST
BALLOT.
AND THEN THE QUESTION IS WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT.
NO ONE HAS ANY IDEA.
THIS HAS NOT HAPPENED FOR A
HUNDRED YEARS.
WE'VE GONE INTO MULTIPLE BALLOTS
BUT THE HOUSE COULD NOT GOVERN
UNTIL THEY ELECT A SPEAKER WHICH
IS WHY THIS COULD GO ON FOR
HOURS.
AND McCARTHY IS SAYING PUBLICLY
AND PRIVATELY, HE'S NOT GOING
ANYWHERE.
HE'S WILLING TO GRIND IT OUT AND
HIS SUPPORTERS ARE WILLING TO DO
THAT TOO BUT THE PROBLEM IS THE
CONSERVATIVE OPPONENTS ARE
SAYING THEY'RE NOT MOVING
EITHER.
>> AND JUST TO STATE THE OBVIOUS
TO YOU TWO, BUT FOR EVERYONE OUT
THERE, McCARTHY LOSES 20
REPUBLICAN VOTES, THAT IS A REAL
WOW MOMENT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS SPEAKER FIGHT.
AND AS MANU IS GETTING AT, THE
HISTORY INVOLVED HERE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE MECHANICS
IN JUST A SECONDBA THERE IS A
LOT THAT COULD GO INTO IT AND
WHAT YOU'RE WATCHING FOR THE
FLOOR FIGHT.
BUT, DAVID, I THINK THE BROADER
CONTEXT IS AN IMPORTANT THING
HERE ABOUT WHAT KEVIN McCARTHY
IS FIGHTING AGAINST IN THIS
MOMENT.
THE WAY HE JUST SAID WHEN IT HE
WENT TO REPORTERS IS HE'S NOT
GOING TO LET -- HE SAID HE'S
FIGHTING AGAINST A FEW
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT SOMETHING
FOR THEMSELVES BUT IT IS MUCH
BIGGER THAN THAT.
>> IT IS.
ALTHOUGH IT WAS SO INTERESTING
TO LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCE IN
KEVIN McCARTHY'S POSTURE AND
TONE YESTERDAY VERSUS TODAY.
YESTERDAY HE PASSED REPORTS IN
THE CAPITOL AND IT WAS ALL ON
THE MIFL.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A GREAT DAY.
TO PUT TO REST AND THAT IS WHAT
KEVIN McCARTHY IS FACING TODAY.
>> SO HE THEN, MANU, LIFT THE
CURTAIN SLIGHTLY FOR WHAT WE --
AND HOW WE CAN WITH THIS.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE MIGHT NOT REALLY KNOW OR
REALLY HONESTLY CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT SOME OF THE STRANGE RULES
OF HOW THE HOUSE OPERATES AND
SOME OF WHAT IS BEING ARGUED AND
NEGOTIATED AND THE COME FROM --
THE COMPROMISED LAID OUT ON THE
TABLE.
WHAT DO THE HOLDOUTS REALLY
WANT.
>> THEY WANT MORE POWER.
THAT IS WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT HAS BEEN
ON THE TABLE IS TO GIVE THEM
MORE LEVERAGE TO CALL FOR A VOTE
TO OUST THE SPEAKER.
HE'S MOVED SIGNIFICANTLY IN
THEIR DIRECTION.
RIGHT NOW THE RULES SAY ABOUT
HALF OF THE MEMBERS COULD CALL
FOR SUCH A VOTE.
HE'S AGREED TO MOVE IT DOWN TO
JUST FIVE MEMBERS AGREEING TO
THAT VOTE TO OUST A SPEAK.
SOME OF THEM WANT IT MOVES DOWN
TO ONE VOTE, ONE MEMBER TO ELECT
THE SPEAKER.
A NUMBER OF CONSERVATIVES HAVE
ASKED TO BE FOR SPECIFIC
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS NOW AND
ANOTHER COMMITTEE TO GIVE THEM
MORE POWER, TO GIVE THEM MORE
LEVERAGE.
McCARTHY HAS NOT BEEN WILLING TO
DO THAT BECAUSE IT IS NOT UNTIL
THE SPEAKER IS NAMING WHERE THEY
COULD GO AND PICK THE CANDIDATES
BECAUSE OF THE RULES WITHIN THE
HOUSE.
SO THERE ARE SOME PUSHBACK AND
DISAGREEMENT.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
MOVEMENT IN KEVIN McCARTHY IN
THE CONSERVATIVES DIRECTION
WHICH IS WHAT IS PROMPTING
ENORMOUS ANGER WITHIN THE RANKS.
NOT JUST WITH McCARTHY, BUT I'M
TOLD IN ONE EXCHANGE HE SAID TO
SCOTT PERRY, THE CONGRESSMAN IS
PUSHING FOR MONTH CHANGES, WHAT
ARE YOU LEFT TO FIGHT FOR
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES HE HAS MOVED
IN THAT DIRECTION.
THEN MOTHER MEMBER CAME OUT
HERE, MATT ROSENDALE, SAID THAT
McCARTHY HAS LIED ABOUT THE
CONCESSIONS THAT HE HAS MADE.
SO YOU'RE SENSING SIGNIFICANT
DISTRUST ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITHIN THE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE
AND LEADING TO ALL SORTS OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THEY COULD
GOVERN, EVEN IF THEY ELECT A
SPEAKER.
BUT THIS VOTE COULD GO ON FOR
SOME TIME.
IT WILL TAKE AN HOUR TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL CALL WHERE
MEMBERS WILL ANNOUNCE WHO THEY
ARE VOTING FOR AND THEN IF THEY
DEEBT GET 218, THEY GET A SECOND
B